for more on the new coronavirus
projections let's bring in our dr. David
agus he's at home - in Los Angeles David
good morning to you you know doctor foul
Qi says don't get discouraged we keep
hearing we good morning to you doctor
foul Qi says don't get discouraged we
keep hearing it's going to be another
difficult couple of weeks which is also
very frightening the projections are
240,000 Americans could die so my
question is how do we not get
discouraged and why are the numbers
jumping so high so quickly well we've
made an impact right with no behavior
change at all it will be one to two
million people dying and we're down to a
hundred to two hundred thousand which is
still way too high but we need to do
much more many of us are as you're doing
now staying in your home and social
distancing and really playing by the
rules some are not some parts of the
country are not equal to others and we
all have to step up there really needs
to be a step up states like Florida and
Texas have to step up more we all have
to stop the spread and we're going to
make an impact we have to look at you
know the medical care we're doing now
can we optimize it can other states
learn from New York City what they did
right and wrong and improve the care so
those numbers come down you know dr.
Burke said there's no magic bullet
there's no vaccine it's just behavior
and what you just said not everybody's
following the rules do you think now we
have to have a federal mandated law
where people are just ordered this is
what you have to do listen this is my
opinion only the answer is yes I think
we need to get normative behavior change
as a country we need leadership and the
leadership needs to come from the
federal government saying hey as a
country we're all going to step up we
are in this together if a few people do
the wrong thing it hurts everybody we
saw that picture this weekend of a beach
in Florida that was totally emptied
because that County said nobody can go
out and go on the beach the county
next-door didn't have that rule and as
soon as you see the county line
you see people lined up and smushed
together we can't have that we are in
this together your behavior affects your
neighbor and vice versa what are the new
models show about the difference in
cases between New York and New Jersey
compared to other parts of the country
well you know New York and New Jersey
now the United States is the epicenter
of this virus in the country New York
and New Jersey of the epicenter of the
epicenter and you know obviously people
smushed into Subway's and and on the
street before this happened enabled
pretty rapid spread my hope is those
same slopes don't happen when you look
at cities like Los Angeles and San
Francisco just a couple weeks ago they
were exactly the same point New York
City is now and you see a New York City
with this crazy increase in the number
of cases and none of the others and so I
think they are had started earlier and
doing better in California with the
social distancing and it works it ain't
fun it ain't good for our pocketbook but
it works and we all have to do it and be
very strict about it you know everybody
keeps hoping treatment vaccine what can
you tell us about the latest treatments
anything well yeah I mean you know
there's a study out yesterday I'm from
China where they randomized a
hydroxychloroquine versus standard care
and in that study and again it wasn't
the best study you can complain that was
Chinese doctors do we trust the data but
there was a dramatic improvement in the
group that got into hydroxychloroquine
and that's about all the data we have
now are these small Chinese studies I
hope and pray that the data of the
United States come soon that we can
learn from every encounter that we're
doing because we're treating patients
now but I want to know what's working
that's critical to finding the curve
yeah everybody's working thank you very
much dr. agus